c'est le plus vieil instituts de
recherche médicale en russie ces mêmes
ici qu'en 1897
evans pavlova développé avec son chien
la célèbre théorie de la salivation et
du conditionnement l'établissement sa
vitesse bora venu me narguer percussions
prestige sauf qu'ils le font dans
l'ombre et souvent sans le financement
approprié
mine de rien dans ce petit pot de
yogourt se trouve un vaccin oral contre
la corée 19 s'affirme confiant
alexandre ouvrables et tous fermés du
muc reach cry
j'ai tout simple dit-il
mais dans les faits il aura fallu des
mois à son équipe pour reproduire puis
introduire les gènes de la coved aux
bactéries laitières et en faire un
antidote au corps navires us qui s'avale
d'un seul coup il est encore tôt mais
déjà les résultats des essais menés sur
ces centaines de souris sont prometteurs
explique le scientifique
des handicaps ont été détectés non
seulement dans le sens des cobayes
mais surtout dans les tissus mucus qui
tapisse les systèmes respiratoires et
digestifs de l'expansion mais comment
expliquer qu'un pays comme la russie qui
a développé et a prouvé son axe un scout
nick quelques semaines n'est pas encore
financé la recherche d'un simple yo
gourd le gouvernement russe comme
partout ailleurs à prioriser les grands
laboratoires et les grandes
pharmaceutiques dit la chercheuse à nice
à pied va il faut l'accepter
l'institut attend son tour pour étendre
la recherche en vertu des protocoles
ils ne sont pas les seuls plusieurs
laboratoires aux états unis se penche
présentement sur le même genre de
vaccins à base de produits et y dérober
d'autant plus qu'il se boit simplement
ce qui permettrait de libérer des
milliers de professionnels de la santé
des campagnes de vaccination en milieu
hospitalier
c'est un square
car plus la pandémie progresse plus
l'intérêt pour son vaccin et croit en
russie alexandre souvorov sm que d'ici
quelques mois
son humour données ferme à la pluie
pourrait enfin être approuvé et si
thammarat intéresse qu radio-canada
saint pétersbourg